also was nun gibt es jetzt plant 9 oder
nicht eine aktuelle studie legt die
vermutung nahe dass einen ring aus
abertausenden kleineren objekten einen
ähnlichen effekt haben könnte wie ein
einzelner planet und eine weitere studie
bestätigt wiederum planet 29 zum science
fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen rein in
die kartoffeln raus aus den kartoffeln
also was stimmt denn nun ist die theorie
vom planet 9 nun entkräftet oder im
gegenteil sogar bekräftigt der reihe
nach ende januar erschien eine studie
mit ja eine ernüchternde these könnte es
sein dass planet 9 gar nicht existiert
ist der planet ein reines hirngespinst
bzw
ist der wunsch vater des gedankens la
damit der grund gefunden warum er plane
im neuen immer noch nicht entdeckt haben
die these ein ring aus aber 1000
objekten die zusammen die bis zu 10
fache erdmasse hätten hätte zusammen den
gleichen effekt auf die umlaufbahn
zahlreicher transnet tunis objekte kurz
dns also als segen ins werk planeten wie
ein einzelner planeten
das sagt die studie von jihad tuma von
der american university of beirut und
abtragen von der university of cambridge
aus planet 9
also fußte kuchen die atome die
hypothese vom kleinen ist faszinierend
wir wollten doch nach roten ob es eine
andere weniger dramatische und
vielleicht natürlichere ursache für die
merkwürdigen baden geben könnte
die wir bei einigen museen ihre studie
berücksichtigt ihren angaben zufolge zum
ersten mal auch den rest des
sonnensystems sie sagen in kombination
mit einem vereinfachten modell des
sonnensystems könnte das die
ungewöhnliche orbital architektur einige
brocken am äußeren ende des
sonnensystems erklären die beiden
wissenschaftler gingen in ihrer studie
von einem gigantischen ring von objekten
aus und tatsächlich er beeinflusst in
die umlaufbahn der transnistrischen
objekte genauso wie ein hypothetischer
planet 9 also hat sich die wissenschaft
gehört dazu muss man sagen nur eins ist
sicher objekte jenseits des neptuns
haben exzentrische umlaufbahn
irgendetwas stört sie so dass es jeweils
beulen in ihrem orbit gibt das ist sich
fach bestätigt und
zweifelhaft doch was verursacht diese
beulen dazu gibt es nur unbestätigte
hypothesen und dazu ist jetzt aktuell
eine weitere hinzugekommen
wenn die zwei der wichtigsten verfechter
der planet neuen theorie haben
zurückgeschlagen
michael braun und konstantin bettingen
vom california institute of technology
caltech haben nun tausende computer
modelle durchgerechnet und damit erneut
überprüft ob planeten existieren könnte
oder nicht und die ergebnisse sind
spektakulär erst mal haben sie die
chance zur planet 9 auf 5 102 1
gerechnet und sie haben eine neue bahn
und eine andere größe von planet neuen
errechnet demnach ist er nicht bis zu
1000 astronomische einheiten das ist der
abstand erde-sonne sondern nur 400 von
der sonne entfernt und er ist nicht bis
zu zehn mal so groß wie die erde sondern
nur bis zu fünfmal zitat bei 50 erstmals
mit neun wahrscheinlich eher einer
typischen extrasolaren supererde das
sagt betten
damit würde auch die möglichkeit eines
gasplaneten entfallen und es könnte sehr
spannend werden wie diese supererde dann
aussieht leben auf exoplaneten neue
erkenntnisse zur entstehung von leben
hier draufklicken für dieses video sehr
sehr spannend also anblicken angucken
abonnieren
bis dann beim können